daily wire reports former president
Donald Trump said Saturday that the Deep
state was coming after him and his
supporters in his first speech since
being indicted on federal charges
related to his handling of classified
documents Trump spoke openly about the
37 count indictment to about 2 000
Republicans gathered in Columbus Georgia
at the state Republican conference the
2024 presidential candidate is accused
of the willful retention retention of
National Defense information corruptly
concealing documents or records and
making false statements Trump said quote
the ridiculous and baseless indictment
of Me by the by demonstration's
weaponized Department of Justice will go
down as among the most horrific abuses
of power in the history of our country
many people have said that Democrats
have even said that this vicious
persecution is a travesty of justice and
then he said in the end they're not
coming after me they're coming after you
and I'm just standing in their way now
um there's obviously been a lot of
discussion about the particulars of this
indictment and the many counts against
Trump 37 counts
uh I'm I'm not interested of course in
in any analysis from anyone in the
Legacy Media or anybody on the left
because
these people will always say that Trump
is guilty of whatever he's accused of
and whatever he's accused of is always
the worst thing anyone's ever done in
history and so that's like we don't need
to listen to their analysis we know
that's what it's going to be
um which is why it's pointless to pay
attention to them but analysis from
people on the right can be interesting
and I've read plenty of that and and I
will say that I've seen a number of
people on this side people I consider
credible and trustworthy saying that
this could be a serious problem for
Trump
and that even if he didn't commit any
crimes he did act
in a way that
made it easy for those who are trying to
take him down you know like handing his
own head on a silver platter basically
and there may be some truth to that you
know it's it's uh
it's not fair it's not right
but the fact is that that we you know if
you're on the right if you're a
conservative
we are all under far more scrutiny than
anyone on the left
um not as much as president Trump is but
uh but obviously but especially those of
us with a platform with a profile and
even if you don't you know you're under
scrutiny and we're held to standards
that the other side isn't held to that's
the fact it's not right but it's the
fact
um it shouldn't be the fact but it is
and so that's all the more reason why we
have to be extremely disciplined very
smart we have to keep our wits about us
so that we we don't hand them an
opportunity to take us out
they might take us out anyway
but if they will
it shouldn't be because we made it easy
on them
you know and and all that is true
but that's still not the point here in
my view because whatever Trump data
didn't do we all know I mean everybody
knows and nobody can credibly deny that
they are going after him for political
reasons that's the motivation behind it
and they're trying to take him down for
things that others like Hillary Clinton
and Joe Biden have also done this is a
politically motivated prosecution which
is being carried out by the president
during an election
against his own Challenger which has
never happened before ever in history I
mean it really is true so when Trump
trump
um
maybe maybe prone sometimes to uh
Hyperbole and you know I will confess
that I am sometimes as well but when he
says that this is no one's ever seen
anything like this before that that is
100 the case like nothing like this has
ever happened before
um
and so if you value our democratic
system that we're always told so much
about and if you want to maintain order
if you want to preserve our
civilization really this is not
something that you do period
you just you just don't do this you
don't try to imprison your political
opponent who is currently running
against you
for the for the same office
the one year anniversary of Roe v Wade
being overturned is coming up and since
then the left has lost their minds
pro-life efforts which are more
important now than ever are booming you
heard that right despite the narrative
pro-lifers didn't go away they increased
in numbers in fact 40 Days for life is
changing hearts and Minds in the most
blue pro-abortion States they've had a
record number of locations uh since a
road was overturned they have grown in
both volunteers and locations with about
1 million Volunteers in 1500 cities they
hold peaceful vigils outside abortion
facilities this success has come with
new unwanted attention from the federal
government and the doj in regards to
free speech as well as one of the
largest pro-life organizations in the
world no one is in a better position 40
Days for life to end abortion in each
state in a post Rural America you can
help them fight the ongoing legal
battles of protecting free speech for
their volunteers help them defend free
speech by giving a tax-deductible gift
of any amount at 40daysforlife.com
that's 40daysforlife.com
that's something that you do if you want
to burn it all down in pursuit of power
and in an effort to demoralize and
terrorize your political enemies
if you care about the system if you care
about preserving our our Democratic way
of life and all the rest of it then you
don't do this but if you don't care
about that
and you want to rip it all to shreds
then this is what you do
and it's what the Bible Administration
is doing
um
so even apart from the facts of the case
this is absolutely their motivation it's
their reasoning and it's a it's a
horrifying reality uh but it is the
reality
which brings me to my last point which
is very simple which is that
Republicans need to win in 2024. I know
that's not uh that's not any big news
here okay I'm not this is not some some
penetrating new insight you hadn't
thought about but I mean it really is
that simple truly
this is why I've said for months now
that in the primaries I'm a single issue
voter
and the single issue is winning
that that's the only thing that matters
it's like we have to win because nothing
else matters if you don't win
everything else that you might do all
the other items on your agenda none of
that means anything if you don't win so
we need to win and that is all that
matters
somebody needs to beat Biden
you cannot be allowed to win re-election
needs to be beaten and then when uh he
is beaten
he needs to be prosecuted
Biden needs to be prosecuted his junky
son Hillary Clinton
her degenerate husband all of them
and then go and pull out Epstein's black
book and prosecute everybody in there I
mean just prosecute everybody
Democrats have to be stopped and there
must be a response
okay they have to understand that when
you escalate there will be a response
there will be backlash there will be
consequences
it's not going to be one-sided
so if you choose to escalate you need to
you need to understand what you're
choosing
you know mutually assured destruction
it's the unfortunately it's the only
path forward
because the other option is one-sided
destruction I mean the best option of
all is no destruction at all like that's
that's what I would prefer if there was
just no destruction but um that option
has been taken away that's just not an
option
and so what we have to choose from is
mutually assured destruction or
one-sided destruction where we are
destroyed but they are not
uh and and that's not an option that I
find particularly appealing I must say
so we have to win um you know and it's
talking about hyperbole you know
unfortunately especially in the in the
social media era and the era of cable
news every single presidential election
before every presidential election
everybody says well this is the election
that's going to make or break us we need
to win or nothing will ever be the same
you know the future of America hangs in
the balance because of this election
um and we've said that many times
and it hasn't quite been true many times
like everybody says that on all sides
this time though it really is different
like I just I can't even it's hard to
fathom
what four more years of this will be
like
um under a you know a president who is
fully has fully succumbed to dementia at
that point completely lost his mind
and so his administration is being run
by people who are not him
um
and where does it go from there it's
hard to even fathom
and we don't want to find out that's all
I can say if you'd like to see what else
I have to say you can access my full
show by going to dailywire.com or by
going to the Matt Walsh Show Twitter
page hope to see you there Godspeed